A squared minus 2a minus 3 divided by the quantity, a squared plus a minus 1 is
correct. I hope these are getting easier. We know the LCD must be a times a
minus 1. Since these are the only factors that appear in our denominators. We
multiply the fraction by the LCD divided by the LCD, so we really multiply each
of these terms by the number a times a minus 1. For our first term the a is
reduced to 1. So we're left with a plus 3 times a minus 1. For the second term
the a minus 1s cancel, leaving us with negative 4 times a. And this is why you
want to be really careful to pay attention to this sign. We have negative 4 a
not positive 4 a, and in our denominator we're left with a times a which is a
squared, and 1 times a minus 1. We add that as our second term in the
denominator. If we multiply these two together we'll get a squared plus 2a minus
3. Our denominator just has the terms a squared plus 1 a minus 1 we combine our
like terms to get negative 2a for our numerator. Now, we definitely want to try
to see if we can simplify this more, but I know I can't. I can't find factors of
negative 1 that sum to positive 1, so we're really done. The numerator can be
factored, but again this doesn't help us out, since we can't cancel a factor
that appears here with one that appears here. This is our final answer.